foreign
Rapids Michigan hi Travis welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Mr Ramsey Dr John deloney it's a
pleasure to speak to you both today you
too what's up
um so I am my question is how do you get
out of debt with my current salary as a
truck driver projected to make 80 000
this year
okay how much is your debt um
total debt is 67 000. um 40 000 is
student loan debt and then I have 11
000 balance on a car and the rest is
credit cards okay you're single I've
been trying to make a
um I am dating currently living with
um my partner and
so that's kind of tricky because when I
moved in with her I was over the road
and now I'm a local driver
um so I I pay her to help her with the
mortgage
um
but we're not married yet planning on
engagement soon so
okay so you are paying part of your
roommates
payment as rent
essentially yes yeah and your rent is
how much
uh 500 a month okay all right so you
make 80 000 a year and you have a 500 a
month rental
okay yep so what's wrong with getting on
a tight tight tight tight tight tight
tight tight budget and beginning to pay
these debts down
you got you you should have all kinds of
margin in this budget
yeah and I've been trying to see that
for myself like I have in my notes all
my bills and credit cards um how much
each monthly payment the sum of them is
for the minimum balance I've been
following uh listening to you guys over
the last couple months for the baby
stats yeah but I just can't seem to get
ahead of you don't you haven't done a
bunch so what is your take-home pay
um about 1200 a week okay you get paid
once a week
correct okay you sit down and you look
at June
how many times are you going to get a
paycheck let's pretend it's four okay
that would give you four thousand eight
hundred dollars to work with
minus 500 for rent
minus food correct minus some car gas
minus the minimum payments on all of
these bills and everything else goes
towards the stupid credit card until
it's gone and you cut up the credit card
I've cut two of them up since I've
started listening to you I've paid I
feel like you drove right past all the
room that should be in this budget forty
eight hundred dollars minus 500 minus
food that's a buttload of money left
over
yeah it's about thirty six hundred
dollars or thirty seven hundred dollars
yeah how much is the balance on the
credit card
um I have three of them left
um
once
2150 600 and 700. okay you should pay
the 60700 off this month and probably
the 2150. yep so you're you're done with
credit cards in two months one month oh
one month let's do it
okay but you're not going out to eat
and you're not going on vacation
and you're not going drinking with your
buddies
you got no life you're getting ready to
clean up your dad gum mess because you
want to get married
yes and it's time to clean up your mess
so what I'm teaching you is what's
called a zero-based budget your income
each month unique to that month minus
every dollar gets an assignment every
dollar has a mission every dollar has a
name beside it before the month begins
before June gets here next week you need
to have figured out what your income for
June is and assign every one of those
dollars first to Necessities food
shelter clothing transportation and
utilities so rent
car payment
car gas
food okay that's it and then everything
else dude we're going at this at these
credit cards like they're the freaking
enemy because they are
yeah if you had 4 800 minus 500 and you
had twenty six hundred dollars makes you
debt free or I'm sorry 20 uh 3 200 makes
you debt free you're debt free of your
credit cards in one month you really
should be
right
that's how you do it absolutely that's
how you do it right there and jump
online and pick up there or hang on
we'll give you uh the every dollar app
and uh we'll get you tied into the uh
Advanced version of the every dollar app
which connects to your bank and helps
you run your budget it's the world's
best budgeting app and it'll help you
but it's giving every dollar a name
that's the point when you get very
detailed very nuanced and very careful
with your planning each and every single
month and you squeeze every one of these
dollars until Benjamin Franklin is
squealing then you are ready to go and
that's what we're doing and we're not
we're not spending money on anything
because we're trying to clean this mess
up so realistically you've got 50 uh
55 000 in debt you make eighty thousand
but you got almost no expenses you
probably could be 100 debt free in a
year
pretty close a year and for everybody
listening I want don't don't blow by
this because it's easy to look at him
and be like man that guy
you can't out earn your your
unintentionality your lack of
intentionality he's making eighty
something thousand dollars a year and he
can't figure out where it's going where
how to pay off a 2000 credit card can't
figure it out and it's not because he's
dumb it's because it's just chaos
there's too many spin in place
everywhere yep and that's what a budget
does it's all it's all
spun up in your brain and then The Ether
and everything else and so giving every
dollar an assignment every time you do
this people those of you that haven't
done it you need to sit down and do it
tonight June's coming next week and you
sit down do your dad gum budget maybe
for the first time in your life put your
income for the month at the top of the
page and then give every dollar an
assignment I will promise you two things
will happen number one thing will happen
is that you will feel like you got to
raise because you will go where is all
this freaking money going
it's going to blow your mind how much
you waste
and the second thing that's going to
happen is you're going to get a sense of
Peace instead of a sense of anxiety even
though you've actually done nothing with
money yet
now you've actually executed a plan that
says if I take these 17 steps I'm going
to be free
and as soon as you see the steps in
front of you then you realize they're
doable your anxiety goes down your uh
stress level goes down your peace level
goes up and you kind of just slick your
hair back and go okay let's get about
the business of doing this let's go game
on